la royal air force est considérée comme
l'une des meilleures aviation de combat
au monde ont même si elle possède
quelques lacunes en raison de sa petite
taille elles compensent largement cet
inconvénient par la qualité de
l'entraînement de ces aviateurs ce qui
permet à la royal air force d'apporter
une contribution significative dans la
résolution des conflits ou qu'ils
puissent survenir
aujourd'hui les capacités de combat de
la royal air force réside dans les
variantes de ces trois avions principaux
le tornado dont la version f3 a en
charge la défense aérienne tandis que la
version gr4 apporte à la royal air force
ses capacités de bombardements le jaguar
est quant à lui utilisé pour les
attaques au sol et la reconnaissance
puis vient l'extraordinaire arrière gers
est capable d'utiliser de toutes petites
surfaces grâce à ses capacités de
décollage et atterrissage vertical
ces trois avions sont propulsé par des
réacteurs une motorisation que la royal
air force utilise depuis bien plus
longtemps que n'importe quel autre armée
de l'air us pendant les années 30
franck whittle a essayé sans succès de
persuader qui voulait bien l'entendre
que ses travaux sur la propulsion à
réaction serait le futur de
l'aéronautique et le monde était en
train de basculer dans la seconde guerre
mondiale et ceux dont la royal air force
avaient besoin c'était de nombreux
avions de chasse rapide et fiable et
pacy engins trop novateur qui ne serait
pas sans poser de nombreux problèmes de
mise au point
du coup whittle fut complètement ignorés
et les constructeurs continuèrent à
produire des avions dotés de moteurs à
pistons mais tandis que la guerre
faisait rage il devint évident que l'ère
des avions de combat à moteur à pistons
arrivait à son apogée
pendant les combats les pilotes
parvenaient presque a frôlé la vitesse
du son lors de certaines manoeuvres en
piqué ce qui les empêchait de franchir
cette vitesse était tout simplement la
résistance de l'air
la combinaison de nouvelles formes plus
aérodynamique
couplé à la puissance théorique mans
illimitée des réacteurs constituer la
solution
la luftwaffe a été la première aviation
introduire un jet dans ses rangs le
messerschmitt m 262 et chouette c'est
elle en flèche son nez pointu et surtout
ces deux turboréacteurs lui permettait
de surclasser même les plus récents
avions de combat conventionnel mais en
1944 l'intensité des bombardements
alliés rendait la production et
l'acheminement des matières premières
très difficile pour l'allemagne
du coup le m me 262 ne plus jamais
atteindre son plein potentiel
opérationnel en juillet 1944 la royal
air force reçu son premier jet de chasse
le gloucester mais d or ces deux
réacteurs rolls royce weylandt lui
autorisait une vitesse de pointe de 750
km heure ce qui n'était qu'un tout petit
peu plus rapide que les autres chasseurs
en service chasseurs qu'ils étaient en
train de gagner la guerre
mais lorsque les allemands commencèrent
à attaquer londres et d'autres villes
anglaises avec leurs bombes volantes 9
et 1
le météore trouve à sa vocation la
population anglaise fut rassuré par
l'arrivée en service du météore capable
de rattraper les v1 et de les descendre
plus facilement que les autres chasseurs
à la fin de la guerre les missions du
météore avait été étendu à la
reconnaissance et à l' attaque au sol
les jets étaient bien adaptées à ces
missions puisque désormais le pilote
bénéficiait d'un bon champ de vision
vers l'avant une fois débarrassé du
moteur et de son hélice le météore fut
rapidement décliné en plusieurs versions
et à la fin de la guerre le mark iii
entra en service mais ce fut le marque 8
introduit dans les années 50 qui se
révéla la plus prolifique de toutes les
versions du météore les nouveaux rolls
royce deroin tu délivres est
significativement plus de puissance avec
une poussée de 1500 kg chacun le météore
atteignait ainsi des vitesses de l'ordre
de 1000 kilomètres heure son armement
comportait quatre canons de 20 mm dans
le nez auquel on pouvait ajouter des
roquettes sous les ailes
et bien que la royal air force comme
toutes les autres forces armées aient vu
ses forces réduites à la fin de la
guerre il y eut quand même trente deux
escadrons de première ligne et 11
escadron auxiliaires doté de médée or le
météore joue un rôle crucial en
permettant à la royal air force ainsi
qu'à d'autres aviation d'entrer dans
l'ère du jet permettant alors à une
nouvelle génération de pilotes de se
familiariser avec les hautes vitesses et
les exigences de ce nouveau mode de
propulsion dans la royal australian air
force les météores furent engagés au
combat mais cette fois encore est ce
conflit vie par ailleurs aussi l'arrivée
d'une nouvelle génération de chasseurs à
elle en flèche capable de dépasser la
vitesse du son face au f 86 sabré ion
1015 soviétique
le météore semblait issu d'une toute
autre époque mais cet avion fut maintenu
en service en angleterre jusqu'au début
des années 60 où il avait évolué vers la
chasse nocturne les versions et 9 11 12
13 et 14 nécessitait un équipage de deux
hommes mais restait très similaire aux
marques 8
bien que notoirement plus lent au boeuf
environ 3500 météores ont été construits
et bien peu ont été conservés en état de
vol ou encore récemment la firme martin
becker à la pointe de la technologie des
sièges éjectables utilisait deux marx
est adapté pour tester ses nouvelles
productions
c'est avec une certaine ironie de
l'histoire que cet avion qui apporte à
temps dans l'exploration des hautes
vitesses et par conséquent qu'il était
presque impossible à évacuer d'urgence
et jouer un tel rôle dans le
développement de cette technologie qui a
sauvé des milliers de pilotes
arrivé trop tard pour participer à la
seconde guerre mondiale le de havilland
vampire joua également un rôle important
dans les premières années jet de la
royal air force
en dépit de ses ailes droite identique
aux avions à hélices de la seconde
guerre mondiale son réacteur de
havilland gobeline lui permettait
d'atteindre 900 km heure quelle que soit
l'altitude mais c'est sa forme bi poutre
qui le rend si parfaitement
reconnaissable aux banques de petite
taille et très agile le vampire était
très populaire auprès de ses pilotes car
très facile à piloter
le vampire s'adjuge a également quelques
records dont 1/1 d'endurance lors d'un
vol transatlantique en 1948 si vampire
mark iii du squadrons 54 ont effectué la
toute première traversée de l'atlantique
par des avions à réaction
une preuve supplémentaire de la
supériorité de ses appareils qui
voyaient leur autonomie et leur rayon
d'action largement accrue le vampire
constitue à la base du nouveau chasseur
bip outre de havilland le venom entrée
en service en 1955 le vampire était doté
d'elle droite alors que le venom
possédait quant à lui une aile avec une
légère flèche
la combinaison de cette aérodynamique
améliorée et du réacteur ghost of plus
puissants permettait aux venom
d'atteindre plus de 11 100 km/heure une
notable amélioration par rapport aux
vampires
1 pour les versions nf2 et nf3 de chasse
de nuit le venom accueillait à un second
membre d'équipage qui s'occupait du
radar placé dans le nez agrandi pour
l'occasion l'événement de chasse
nocturne ont été fournis également à
l'afrique est un arm comme chasseur tout
temps la fleet her arms l'aviation
embarquée anglaise est entré dans l'ère
de la réaction beaucoup plus tard que la
royal air force son premier jet le super
marine attacker à trains classiques ne
fut pas un triomphe mais il joue un rôle
substantiel en initiant la marine
anglaise a utilisé les avions à réaction
à partir des pont d'envol de ses porte
avions le venom souffrait néanmoins de
quelques défauts essentiellement de la
fragilité de sa crosse d'appontage de
nombreux venom n'ayant pas réussi à
monter correctement en raison de la
défaillance de sept pièces vitales ont
dépassé le pont du navire et se sont
écrasés en mer le vent coeur si rock fut
une étape essentielle des progrès de
l'aéronavale anglaise la navy avaient
enfin réceptionné un chasseur
suffisamment polyvalent pour assurer la
défense aérienne de la flotte ainsi que
l'émission d' attaque tout en étant
assez solides pour les délicates
opérations embarqué motorisés par
rolls-royce naine il pouvait juste
atteindre la vitesse de 1000 km heure au
niveau de la mer un important réservoir
de carburant était placé à l'arrière du
fuselage autorisant une autonomie de
1400 km lorsqu on ajoutait à l'avion ses
réservoirs externes supplémentaires
mais si les nouveaux jets de la marine
devenait plus rapides que leurs
prédécesseurs à hélices il grossissait
et s'alourdissait de plus en plus lancer
ses avions et les faire atterrir sur le
pont d'un navire devenait de plus en
plus délicat en raison de la petite
taille des porte-avions britanniques une
avancée spectaculaire eut lieu en 1952
avec l'introduction de la catapultes à
vapeur
cette invention anglaise constituait en
fait à prélever pour la catapulte la
vapeur sous pression sur le circuit des
machines de propulsion du navire
la puissance supplémentaire ainsi
offerte pour le catapultage permettait
d'envisager de futurs avions embarqués
plus grand et en portant un armement
plus importante
mais ces avions présenté aussi leur lot
de nouveaux problèmes essentiellement
lors de la ponte âge si les pilotes
apprécié la stabilité et la visibilité
apportée par les avions à réaction
ces engins étaient plus lourds et avait
donc des vitesses d' approche plus élevé
les systèmes de sécurité habituelles
devenait totalement inadapté la solution
vient d'une nouvelle innovation anglaise
le pont oblique celle us navy qui très
rapidement remarqua le potentiel de
cette idée et dès 1952 des essais furent
conduits sur le ss entier ta main
lanthier tam était un porte-avions de la
casse et sexe similaire en taille au hms
eagle alors le plus gros porte avions
anglais de l'époque
l'introduction du public supprimer la
nécessité d barrière d'arès et le risque
de collision avec les avions garés à
l'avant du pont et douce l'efficacité
opérationnelle des porte-avions en était
augmentée car il était aussi possible de
procéder simultanément au catapultage et
osa pontage en 1956 les sis aux 2 6
quadron de la fuite r armes ont
participé aux opérations sur suez en
attaquant les aérodromes égyptien
escorté par d'événements
alors que la marine anglaise commençait
à maîtriser la réaction la royal air
force recevait le premier d'une toute
nouvelle génération de jets ou la guerre
de corée qui avait commencé en 1950
alarme à l'occident cette guerre
préfigurait en effet ce qui pourrait se
passer en cas de conflit plus important
la participation anglaise à la guerre
aérienne sur ce théâtre d'opérations fut
dévolu aux chasseurs à hélices de la
royal navy
les six fleury l'arrivée des chasseurs
moderne f-86 sabre et surtout mis quinze
russe obligea les britanniques à
renforcer leur aviation deux nouveaux
modèles furent commandés en priorité
absolue pour remplacer le météore dans
ses missions de défense aérienne le
super marine swift arrivé en 1951
s'avéra être une véritable déception
dans la mission d'intercepteurs à haute
altitude qui lui était dévolu il fut
donc retiré des unités de première ligne
dès 1955
le rockeur hunter entrer en service dans
la royal air force en 1954 se révèle a
quant à lui une véritable réussite
dès 1956 15 escadrons de la royal air
force furent équipés de la version f 6
qui sera la variante la plus produite du
20 heures
la puissance du 20h lui été fournie par
un rolls royce avant de 5000 kg de
poussée ses formes aérodynamiques et sa
puissance lui permettait même de
franchir le mur du son toutefois en
léger pic est une grande première pour
un avion de construction anglaise enfin
le routeur possédait des points
d'attaché sous les ailes pour emporter
de l'armement
ainsi ces quatre canons de 20 mm situé
sous le nez purent être complété par le
premier missile air air anglais le
ferais fario flash
malheureusement les douilles vides
éjecté par les canons pouvait être
aspiré par le réacteur l'endommageant
gravement à partir de la variante marque
6 ce problème fut résolue par les deux
boss situé sous les entrées d'air
destiné à récupérer ces douilles vides
au moment où le marxiste commencé sa
carrière la première version biplace
d'entraînement le thé marque 7 était
elle aussi introduites
1972 center ont été produits dans de
nombreuses versions jusqu'en 1966 preuve
des qualités de cet avion il fut utilisé
par 22 forces aériennes à travers le
monde et pour certaines jusque dans les
années 90 c'était aujourd'hui quelques
exemplaires vole toujours aux mains de
propriétaires privés
ils sont visibles souvent lors de
meetings et rappelle ce que sous l'âge
d'or de la réaction
le successeur du 20h fut le english
électrique lightning le lightning était
une nouvelle étape technologique
importante car avec lui la royal air
force passée d'un coup de chasseurs
subsonic un avion capable d'atteindre
mach 2 le projet avait commencé en 1947
et culmine à en août 1954 avec le
premier vol du prototype lebihan le p1
et est propulsé par deux turboréacteurs
bristol cibler mais le temps que le
lightning arrive en escadron en octobre
ces moteurs avaient été remplacés par
deux rolls royce à vannes les
performances du lightning était
stupéfiante non seulement capable
d'atteindre mach 2 soit deux fois plus
rapide que le 20 heures ils pouvaient
grimper à l'altitude de 16 mm en une
seule minute mais le prix à payer pour
ses performances étaient une
consommation de carburant tels que sa
faible autonomie le cantonner à un rôle
de défense de zone
le lightning bénéficié d'une
amélioration notable avec la version f 6
en avril 1964 version qui reçu un
réservoir ventrale ce qui doublait la
capacité en carburant des versions
antérieures
le problème de l'endurance fut également
résolu avec l'arrivée du ravitaillement
en vol
intune en juin 1967 le squadrons 74 vola
sans escale jusqu'à singapour cet
exploit peu ordinaire montre l
importance du ravitaillement en vol pour
les missions du lightning les lightnings
f6 reçurent également des réservoirs
supplémentaires disposer au dessus de
l'ale le ravitaillement en vol avec un
light in demandait de l'entraînement
étant donné que la perche n'était pas
dans laxe de l'avion le lightning a
aussi été le premier chasseur anglais à
recevoir un système d'armes complet
missiles et radars intégrer le radar
monter dans le nez et est seulement
capable de repérer ces cibles vers
l'avant mais comme le lightning avait
été conçu pour intercepter les
bombardiers russes à haute altitude
ceci ne posait pas de problème du moins
dans un premier temps une fois le radar
verrouillé sur sa cible les missiles
étaient mis à feu ces missiles se
verrouillait à leur tour sur le
rayonnement infrarouge soit la chaleur
émise par les propulseurs de la cible au
début des années 60 certains étaient
convaincus que ces nouveaux missiles air
air et l arme absolue pour le combat
aérien
la combinaison de la portée du radar et
du missile repoussait le combat au delà
du champ de vision du pilote
ceci était particulièrement important si
le lightning arriver à remplir sa
mission principale détruire en vol les
bombardiers nucléaire soviétique
enfin à part ses domiciles le lightning
n'avait aucun autre armement ce qui
signifiait que si pour une raison ou une
autre les missiles n'atteignaient pas
leurs cibles
le pilote était alors totalement démunis
lorsque la version m6 arrive à les
pilotes avaient enfin récupérer des
canons de aden de 30 mm avaient été
montés dans une nacelle ventrale il
pouvait servir à rappeler à ses
adversaires que même sans ces missiles
le lightning avait encore du répondant
ces années 60 vous voyez le monde
apprendre à vivre dans une guerre froide
qui pouvait à tout moment basculer hors
de contrôle dans l'horreur d'une guerre
nucléaire
on la royal air force jouait donc un
rôle vital en fournissant une force de
défense crédible pour le nord de
l'europe en compagnie de ses alliés de
l'otan
l'époque était celle des quick réaction
alerte ou réaction rapide aux alertes
typiquement en 2 lightning armée et
avitailler était en permanence près en
bout de piste les pilotes en tenue de
vol dans un abri tout proche lorsqu'une
alerte retentit c'est il sautait dans
leur avion et décoller en quelques
minutes de nuit comme de jour et par
tous les temps
le lightning joue à son rôle de chasseur
de première ligne pour l'otan jusqu'en
1976 date à partir de laquelle il fut
progressivement retirées
la carrière du lightning traversa des
années qui furent difficiles pour la
royal air force
quelques tergiversations politiques
ayant eu un impact profond sur cette
arme
le plus évident de ses changements de
cap a été l'annulation du projet tsr2 le
tsr 2 était prévu pour devenir le nouvel
avion d'attac tactique et de
reconnaissance équipé pour cela d'une
technologie de pointe devant faire de
lui l'avion le plus avancé de son époque
une fois en service mais le coût du
développement des passes a amplement les
estimations initiales
et alors que le prototype se révéler
très prometteur lors de ces essais en
vol le gouvernement de l'époque pris la
décision d'annuler le tsr2 cette
décision très controversée divise
l'opinion aujourd'hui encore ceci crée à
une lacune dans les capacités de la
royal air force lacunes qui pris
beaucoup de temps à être compensée
tandis que la royal air force effectuer
sa transition vers la chasse
supersonique la fleet her arms recevait
quant à elle son premier avion à aile en
flèche le super marine scimitar entra en
service avec le squadrons 803 en 1958
conçu pour remplacer le siloc dans son
rôle d'avion d'attac le scimitar était
un avion beaucoup plus volumineux en
plus de ces quatre canons aden le
scimitar pouvaient emporter jusqu'à
quatre missiles air air sagouine d'heure
où une bombe nucléaire
mais en dépit de ces deux rolls royce à
vonn le scimitar restait un avion succès
de surcroît sept avions connu une
invraisemblable série d'accidents sur
les 76,6 mitard construit plus de la
moitié ont été perdus accidentellement
ceux ci étaient principalement la
conséquence de l'emploi par la royal
navy d'avions de plus en plus gros de
plus en plus rapides et de plus en plus
lourd sur de petits porte avions une
dans la seconde moitié des années 50 la
navy reçu le 2 haviland civique sonne
pour remplacer ces venom en défense
aérienne les fans choix
comme le vampire et le venom le civic
sun était aussi un bip outre qui
aujourd'hui encore en raison de sa
taille paraît toujours aussi
impressionnant les premiers appareils et
qui perd trois escadrons fin 1957
c'était le premier chasseur britannique
dépourvues de canons et transportant
uniquement des missiles
en 1965 les premières versions furent
remplacés par la variante f&a w2 comme
ses prédécesseurs il s'agissait d'un
intercepteur tout en mai à l'autonomie
plus importante en raison de réservoirs
supplémentaires logés dans les poutres
le civic sonne fut conservée en service
jusqu'en 1966 en 1962 la navy pris en
compte sont plus puissants appareils
pour l'époque le blackburn but caennais
excellent lors des attaques à basse
altitude le b tenir était à la fois
super sonic est très manoeuvrant à
proximité du sol doté d'une large
variété d'armements conventionnels et
domicile
le buccaneer pouvait aussi emporté une
arme nucléaire
l'avion était propulsé par deux bristol
sidley giron junior remplacé ensuite sur
la version s mark ii en 1965 par des
rolls royce plus puissants
en 1969 les buccaneers entamer une
seconde carrière lorsque la royal air
force récupérera les avions retiré de
l'aviation embarquée renommée s2a les
buccaneers compensèrent l'annulation du
tsr2 ils se sont révélés très efficaces
dans leurs missions d'attac ou de
reconnaissance à longue distance et à
très basse altitude
en tout la royal air force commandes à
42 buccaneer et hérita de 60 avions
supplémentaires provenant de la fuite
est rarement
le but gagnant n'était pourtant qu'une
manière de compenser provisoirement
certains manques
le rôle de la royal air force avaient
évolué dans les années 60 passant du
rôle purement stratégique d'une force
nucléaire vers des missions tactiques
avec un armement plus conventionnel de
nouveaux avions était donc nécessaire
pour ces nouvelles exigences en 1969 le
plus original des avions à avoir jamais
été utilisée par la royal air force
entrée en service au squad rond un le
harrier gr9 finalité du harrier et de
pouvoir décoller et atterrir
verticalement ceux qui ont fait l'avion
idéal pour l'appui tactique avant c'est
l'échec laventure de cet avion
exceptionnel commence en 1957 par une
initiative privée de vos coeurs de
construire un avion d' attaque autour du
tout nouveau réacteur bristol pegasus ce
moteur a été conçu pour que ça pousse et
passe par quatre buses mobile ce qui
assure ainsi la sustentation même pour
un avion à voilure fixe
du coup ce nouvel appareil disposait
d'un grand potentiel pour épauler les
forces terrestres puisque capable d'être
mis en oeuvre à partir de zones
improvisé tout proche de la ligne de
front les premiers harrier de la royal
air force entrait en service en juillet
1969 à ce moment plusieurs nations dont
la france l'allemagne et les usa portait
un grand intérêt au développement de cet
avion
après des essais intense sur terre et
sur mer
l' us marine corps fut autorisé à
commander ses premiers 100 de harrier
dynamisant ainsi le programme
au début des années 80 une nouvelle
version le gr3 entrer en service cette
variante possédait un télémètre laser
monter dans le nez et un moteur amélioré
simultanément la fleet her arms
commençait à recevoir ses premiers
exemplaires du sea harrier
le sea harrier était différent sur de
nombreux points de ses homologues de la
royal air force
par exemple son nez était élargi pour
accueillir un nouveau radar et le
cockpit été réhaussées pour à la fois
recevoir une avionique récents tout en
apportant une meilleure visibilité aux
pilotes
comparé aux avions embarqués
précédemment le harrier possède une
envergure beaucoup plus courte ce qui
lui permet d'opérer à partir de petits
porte-avions voire même d'autres navires
aussi le sea harrier arrivé au moment où
on se demandait si l'angleterre devait
conserver des avions conventionnels dans
la marine sous trois petits porte
aéronefs ont été commandés pour lesquels
le harrier convient parfaitement
ces nouveaux navires possède un pont
d'envol radicalement différent avec une
rampe permettant aussi harrier de
décoller avec une charge plus lourde
tout en utilisant une longueur de pont
très courte 6 mai le harrier était tout
juste devenus opérationnels lorsque
l'argentine envahi les îles malouines le
2 avril 1982 et il s'en suivit une lutte
acharnée pour leur souveraineté
le gouvernement britannique de margaret
thatcher ne voulut pas céder et une
force expéditionnaire fut mis sur pied
en urgence pour confirmer l'exigence
anglaise d'un retrait des forces
argentines sans support aérien le corps
expéditionnaire n'avait aucune chance et
une force de vinci harrier et harrier gr
iii de la royal air force fut embarqué
sur les porte aéronefs invincible et
hermès en route vers l'atlantique sud
ils furent un peu plus tard rejoint par
huit appareils supplémentaires la
campagne devait être un test difficile
pour ces avions encore non éprouvées au
combat contre eux l'argentine déployer
une aviation puissante composé de
skyrock américain de daguerre d'origine
israélienne et deux mirage
le 21 mai les troupes anglaises établir
une tête de pont dans la baie de san
carlos sous les attaques répétées de
l'aviation argentine il pu retenir bon
grâce aux harrier qui à bâtir 13
chasseurs ennemis pour la perte d'un
seul arrière gr iii mais la force des
rares year assez dispersées est limité
ne pouvait pas tout couvrir
d'autant plus qu'il ne bénéficiait
d'aucun système de surveillance et d'
alerte aéroportée peau chez les navires
du corps expéditionnaire mouillé dans
l'aisance et les criques de la baie
devenant des cibles faciles pour les
avions d'attac argentin certains furent
touchés le 4 mai le hms chef il devient
le premier navire de guerre anglais
perdu depuis 37 ans lorsqu'il fut coulé
par un missile exocet tirée par un super
étendard
son sistership coventry fut sévèrement
endommagé par une autre attaque mais les
porte aéronefs demeurait intact d'une
pendant la campagne
sea harrier furent perdues par accident
ou en raison de tirs en provenance du
sol
aucun n'a été descendu en combat aérien
les pertes de l'aviation argentine
furent d'une centaine d'avions
leur arrière s'est bien acquitté de sa
tâche mais pour développer et améliorer
son potentiel de substantiels
investissements devenait nécessaire
mcdonnell douglas avait développé une
version agrandie elle du harrier pour
répondre aux exigences du marine cops
qui désirait un harrier avec une
capacité d'emport encore plus importante
au avec leur arrière tout mcdonnell
douglas devint le principal fournisseur
de l'angleterre en construisant ce
nouvel appareil sous licence une ombre
en 1990 les premiers gers est entré en
service dans la royal air force
il était capable d'emporter deux fois
plus de charges que le gr iii sur une
même distance
au total 96 avions avaient été commandés
dont 62 gr5 version intérimaire qui fut
ensuite porté aux standards gr7 le gers
est équipé d'un flir ou visualisation
par infrarouge qui couplé à des lunettes
de vision nocturne autorise le vol de
nuit à très basse altitude
bien qu optimisé pour les opérations à
basse altitude à des vitesses
supersoniques le harrier s'accommode
idéalement des opérations à moyenne
altitude où il peut utiliser son système
d' attaque composée d'une autre télé et
d'un désignateur laser en somme
même équipé d'une technologie de pointe
le harrier demeure un appareil
polyvalent pouvant être déployées
proches des zones d'opération une
capacité qui est régulièrement utilisé
pendant les exercices militaires depuis
son arrivée en service le gr7 a été
déployé sur un certain nombre de points
chauds les opérations récentes ont
permis aux parieurs d'appuyer les forces
de l'otan et des nations unies au kosovo
en bosnie en serbie et dans le golfe
cette fois depuis les navires de la
royal navy jeune fille depuis l'an 2000
les harrier de la royal air force et les
sea harrier de la navy ont été
rassemblées sous la seule autorité de la
john force harrier le marieur va
continuer ses missions pour encore
plusieurs années et de nombreuses
améliorations sont toujours à l'étude
afin de le maintenir un haut niveau de
capacité opérationnelle
le scpk jag war a été conçu pour
satisfaire les demandes franco anglaise
en 1965 pour un avion d'entraînement
avancé et d'apathie après un
développement prolongé à émerger un
avion bien plus puissant que ce qui
avait été envisagé à l'origine les
premiers jaguar monoplaces ont été
livrés à la royal air force en mars 1974
en moins de deux ans huit escadrons de
première ligne avait reçu leur jaguar
chez le monoplace jaguar s a été rejoint
par le biplace d'entraînement jaguar b
le jaguar se montra particulièrement
efficace dans son rôle de chasseur
bombardier mission pour laquelle il
possède un système de navigation fiable
et un télémètre laser
il est également supersonique à toutes
ces altitudes opérationnel il peut en
outre atterrir sur des pistes
relativement courtes ce qui signifie que
le jaguar peut opérer à partir
d'aérodrome avancé en soutien des
troupes terrestres
ces dernières années les jaguars de la
royal air force ont subi un programme de
modernisation majeur est désigné jaguar
gr 3 août et 4 pour les biplaces cette
modernisation comprend une avionique
moderne comportant un gps un système de
navigation avec référencement de terrain
des jumelles de vision nocturne à un
collimateur de casques et de nouveaux
écrans tête haute et tête basse dans le
cockpit
ici nous avons les deux canadiennes de
20 mm
les jaguars en a deux un de chaque côté
ceci la partie principale de larmes qui
se prolonge vers l'avant avec le canon
les munitions sont dans un compartiment
au dessus elle descendait sont percutés
les deux villes étant éjecté par
l'arrière nous avons 150 vu par canaux
et une cadence de tir de 20 au lieu la
seconde
il renforce d'une seconde permet
d'envoyer 40 au but sur la sips qu'il
est pas mal du tout mise à part les
armes d'exercice nous utilisons deux
types de bulles principaux 1 et chez jo
bhi perforant utilisé contre les cibles
blindées et cher et les achats ea
explosion qui fonctionnent comme de
petite grenade il explose à l'impact et
sature la zone comme une grenade à
fragmentation
dsk une rafale d'une seconde de 40 au vu
de ce type sur une cible est très
efficace
le télémètre laser et et acteurs de
cibles marquer se trouve dans le nez ce
n'est pas un dessinateur de cible il
possède deux fonctions la détection d'un
faisceau laser le calcul de distance le
télémètre laser est la solution idéale
pour larguer des bombes avec précision
le faisceau laser été mis depuis cette
boîte où il est envoyé vers la cible
puis se reflète sur elle
le calculateur analyse temps et calcule
la distance nous indique également la
direction précise de l'objective ainsi
qu'une distance précise vers las il est
alors possible dollars ciel-et-blanc
avec une grande précision
le faisceau laser n'est pas sans danger
il peut causer de graves lésions
oculaires jusqu'à cette masse de
distance nous devons être extrêmement
prudent lorsque nous l'utilisons si nous
avons des forces spéciales au sol avec
un des igloos acteurs ils peuvent
braquer le rayon qui reste invisible lui
vers la cible
le détecteur de rayons a balayé de
droite à gauche comme ceux ci y trouver
le faisceau en quelque sorte il nous
indique verrou nous diriger il va nous
indiquer la distance et le moment où
nous allons pouvoir larguer de bombes
le jaguar possèdent sept points dans le
corps 5 sous les ailes et le fuselage et
deux au dessus des ailes ces 5 pylônes
il y en a deux souches à qu'elle est un
sous le fuselage emprunt centrale
l'autonomie de la géo est amélioré par
les réservoirs supplémentaires comme
vous le voyez ici sous les poids
intérieur ou sous le point central
ici on va sous les pylônes extérieur des
langes manque d'exercice au 14 qui
emportent des petites bombes
d'entraînement l'inventaire le d'emport
la configuration standard est composé de
deux à quatre bombes demi livre freiner
ou lisses ou bien deux à quatre bombes à
sous munitions est toujours un réservoir
supplémentaire sous le point central
sur ces points centrale au poteau à voir
aussi les systèmes de défense comme le
symat fimat est un long fleuve qui
utilisent même principe que les leurs en
aluminium utilisé pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale ici se trouve le
réacteur adour dire la deux c'est le
même moteur qui équipe le hockey mais la
partie arrière diffère il est un peu
plus grande
à l'intérieur on distinct qu'une rampe
circulaire c'est ici que l'on injecte du
carburant pour la postcombustion quant
au langage cela dégage une poussée
supplémentaire avec une longue flammes
d'environ trois mètres
le spectacle de la postcombustion et de
cette lan flammes la nuit est quelque
chose de vraiment impressionnant la
cuillère que vous voyez là ont pour
fonction de maintenir constante la
pression à la sortie du réacteur
quand on met les gaz la pression à
l'intérieur du réacteur augmente
énormément et rapidement pour tâcher de
maintenir cette pression a même niveau
les pétales du réacteur s'ouvre pour
relâcher la pression
en fait si on avait une pression à
l'arrière du réacteur plus importante
que dans les parties antérieures de la
turbine la poussée ne pourrait pas se
faire et on aurait même des retours de
flamme ou infiniment de pompage sérieux
le jaguar a également fait ses preuves
au combat en assurant une part
significative de la contribution
britannique à l'opération desert storm
la première guerre contre l'irak en 1991
si aujourd'hui il ne reste que deux
unités sur jaguar les autres ont été ré
équiper de tornado les jours du jaguar
dans la royal air force ont désormais
compter le gouvernement ayant annoncé la
dissolution en 2006 des dernières unités
pour des raisons budgétaires
le pana via tornado représente un
remarquable succès de coopération
internationale trois pays ont en effet
participé au programme tornado l'italie
l'allemagne et la grande bretagne
le projet était initialement désigné mrc
à avions de combat multi rôles et c'est
cette capacité de polyvalence qui a
failli mener l'ensemble à l'échec car
les trois pays avaient des exigences
très différentes
le tornado se distingue par ses ailes à
géométrie variable pour les manoeuvres à
basse vitesse pour l'atterrissage et le
décollage
les ailes sont dans la position avant à
moyenne vitesse les elle glisse vers une
position intermédiaire améliorant la
manoeuvrabilité de l'appareil pour les
vitesses supersoniques puisque le
tornado peut atteindre mach 2 les ailes
sont complètement replié une autre
caractéristique unique du tornado et
d'avoir été conçu en deux versions
bombardier et chasseurs le programme mrc
à a commencé en 1962 avec l'annulation
du projet tsr de la royal air force
voyez ses capacités grandement
handicapée si aucune solution de
remplacement n'était trouvé ainsi le
coût a été la principale cause de
l'abandon du tsr2 il était clair que
l'industrie aéronautique anglaise était
incapable de proposer de nouveaux
matériels sur ses seules capacités en
dépit d'énormes difficultés le premier
prototype du tornado vola en août 1974
la phase de développement du tornado
s'est prolongée et les premiers gr1 de
bombardements ont été livrés à la royal
air force
en 1981 une structure tri national
d'entraînement a été créé sur la base de
coton sport pour former les équipages de
tornado des trois nations
et là les équipages étaient entraînés
aux bases des opérations sur tornado
avant de rejoindre les unités de
transformation opérationnelle
mais plus le tornado avancé dans son
développement plus les exigences des
forces aériennes divergeaient conduisant
finalement à la fermeture de la
structure pour les équipages de la royal
air force
les missions opérationnelles sont
constitués de vol à très basse altitude
les collines des gosses et le lake
district sont régulièrement sillonnées
par des tornado empruntant le fond des
valets après avoir effectué leurs
attaques d'entraînement dont 7 5 me est
une technique qui a fait la réputation
des équipages anglais et qui a prouvé
son efficacité
quand les tornado reçu le baptême du feu
au cours de la guerre du golfe en 1991
il était essentiel que l'importante
aviation irakiennes soient neutralisées
avant que la bataille terrestre ne
commence la royal air force fut chargé
de détruire les pistes des bases
irakiennes avec les bombes
jp 233 spécialement conçu pour cet usage
les tornado ont lancé leur attaque en
prenant beaucoup de risques au ras du
sol face à de véritables murs de tirs
anti-aériens et le prix à payer fut
lourd cinq avions ont été descendus dès
les premiers jours mais une fois ce
travail accompli les tornado ont repris
la campagne de bombardements plus
sereinement en utilisant des bombes
guidées laser depuis la moyenne altitude
juste après la fin de la guerre du golfe
le tornado gr 1 et a subi une mise à
jour pour devenir le gr4 dont les
premiers exemplaires sont arrivés en
1998 le squadrons 5 à 1 servi d'unités
de transformation opérationnelle à
l'osmose en écosse nous avons ici un
collimateur tête haute qui précise les
informations nécessaires au vol
il est beaucoup plus large que celui que
nous avions avant et il a été largement
amélioré il peut aussi afficher une
image en infrarouge provenant du fuyard
pour ça une amélioration des symboles
affichée a été faite au dessous on a cet
écran qui est à la place de l'ancienne
carte digitale du tornado gir 1
il sait ramener les attaques car il
affiche une image haute résolution
infrarouge depuis le client c'est la
répétition de l'image affichée sur les
écrans du navigateur qantas arrière le
manche est lui aussi singulièrement
différent dessus du géra il possède des
fonctions bien plus avancé nous avons la
possibilité d'engager les systèmes de
pilotage en nous référant au boîtier du
directeur de vol cela nous permet de
voler aussi bien en vol normal vfr que
de passer en conditions de vol aux
instruments
nous avons aussi toujours par rapport
aux gerin la possibilité d'actionner le
flir en appuyant sur un bouton époux
vont s'y mettre en oeuvre également les
contre mesures électroniques se mange
possède des fonctions bien plus avancée
que ce que nous avions sur le gerra ici
les instruments sont disposés comme sur
le gérant
ces instruments sont aussi disponibles
en place arrière avec ici à gauche les
instruments moteur et à droite les jauge
de carburant et l'indicateur de
ravitaillement en vol sur la console de
droite nous avant le panneau des larmes
et à gauche
nous avons des systèmes qui sont
associés avec la visualisation tête
haute
en fait nous avons du coup moins besoin
de nous y référer
et nous gardons le regard sur la chute
et tout ceci vous montre les
améliorations qui ont été apportées sur
le gr 4
le principal changement apporté autant
ados gr4 est la visualisation infrarouge
par le système fuir je sélectionne le
système sur ce boîtier est l'image
s'affiche sur cet écran télé les bonnes
journées la qualité de la visualisation
dépend en effet des conditions
météorologiques du jour entre autres et
on peut tout à fait reconnaître les
détails d'une cible et l'identifier à
partir de là il nous est possible de
mener l'attaqué tout en maintenant la
mise à jour des informations sur notre
position relative les opérations à bord
du gr 4 se font désormais à l'aide d'un
gps intégré ici qui sert pour la
navigation initial en fait mon travail
principal et le rend beaucoup plus
facile en bénéficient également d'une
avionique largement améliorée et qui
comporte également des systèmes de
guerre électronique
la technologie du tornado gr4 est d'une
efficacité sans comparaison
pour mener à bien les opérations et pour
obtenir une bonne efficacité
il est quand même nécessaire de garder
un entraînement permanent
la version de défense aérienne ou
tornado à des v a été développée à
partir du tornado gère 1 de
bombardements et effectua son premier
vol en octobre 1979
jusqu'en 1986 c'est la première version
intermédiaire f2 qui équipait la royal
air force
jusqu'à ce que la version définitive f3
soit prête cette année-là équipé du
radar fox hunter et de plus puissants
réacteurs l'avion a remplacé les vieux
lightning et fantômes pour la défense
aérienne la qualité essentielle du f3 et
sa capacité à effectuer des patrouilles
à longue distance de sa base de départ
et ses patrouilles peuvent être étendue
grâce au ravitaillement en vol il est
dans son rôle d'intercepteurs le f3 peut
recevoir en temps réel des informations
via des liaisons de données sur les
cibles en approche depuis les awacs
entry et ainsi pouvoir attaquer sans se
servir de son propre radars toujours
très peu discret et qui peut alerter
l'ennemi de la même façon dans son rôle
anti radar le f3 peut transmettre ces
informations vers les sentries ou les
stations radar sur la position d'un site
radar et demi et servir de relais pour
d'autres avions ou des forces terrestres
le f3 est armé d'un canon de 27 mm plus
quatre missiles à moyenne portée sky
flash et 4 sidewinder à courte portée
quelques exemplaires ont été modifiés
pour remporter un missile anti radar
tous les avions deux premières lignes de
la royal air force sont en service
depuis au moins 20 ans et ont déjà subi
un bon nombre d'évolutions mais ceci ne
peut pas être éternel bien sûr 20 ans
est une longue période en termes
d'aviation et la technologie attentes
évoluent et qu'il faut porter au crédit
de leurs qualités essentielles
le fait que le tornado le jaguar et le
harrier soit resté en service si
longtemps bientôt le tornado en f3 et le
jaguar seront remplacés par un avion
directement conçu pour le 21e siècle
l'eurofighter typhoon le projet initial
a débuté en 1983 quand un nouveau
prototype expérimental a été commandé
pour évaluer certaines nouvelles
technologies le résultat fut le ap qui
effectua son premier vol en 1986 juste
trois ans après que le feu vert a été
donné et dupeux ap découla des
spécifications pour le futur eurofighter
qui fit son premier vol en 1994
bien que produit à la fin de la guerre
froide
le typhon est suffisamment polyvalent il
peut effectuer des opérations de
supériorité aérienne et conduire des
attaques au sol au cours d'une même
sorti ses performances sont étonnantes
conçu pour être le plus léger possible
et doté d'une importante puissance
le tiff ou ne peut atteindre 40 mille
pieds soit 12000 mètres en 2 minutes
départ arrêté j'en ai pour le tifo entre
actuellement en service au sein de la
royal air force
les premières livraisons sont faites à
wharton l'unité d'évaluation
opérationnels dont les capacités seront
pleinement atteinte en demie
6 ou 2007 dans quel type d'action le
tifo sera engagée il est difficile de le
deviner beaucoup d'avions présenté ici
n'ont jamais eu à subir le test ultime
celui du combat car leur seule existence
était dissuasive
face à des attaques potentielles et
l'ennemi dominant soviétique a juste
disparu pour laisser place à d'autres
dangers à ce jour en dépit de deux
conflits majeurs au moyen-orient et au
dessus de la yougoslavie
les avions anglais n'ont pas eu à
combattre d'autres avions et même le
gouffre technologie qui s'est élargie
n'est plus une garantie contre des
attaques dans le futur le coût de
développement grandissant d'avion
nouveau est incroyablement plus
complexes signifie qu'il n'y aura plus
jamais de jet anglais mais l'industrie
britannique continuera sans doute à
jouer un grand rôle dans la conception
des avions du futur